guerre qui se rapproche aussi d'odessa
le port de la mer noire est l'un des
objectifs de poutine pour la première
fois les russes auraient bombardé les
faubourgs de la ville informations des
autorités locales ukrainienne d'après
elle des immeubles d'habitations ont été
touchées il n'y aurait pas de victime
notre équipe se trouve à micola yves
c'est la dernière grande ville avant
odessa et sur place aussi il ya eu
d'importants bombardements écouté le
compte rendu de julie d'une de l'ofs
avec amara la médaille oui
le centre ville de nicolet yves cette
ville qui se trouve à 130 kilomètres
d'eau dessalée depuis ce matin nous
entendons d'intenses bombardements il ya
quelques heures à 13 heures heure locale
cet immeuble a été bombardé il s'agirait
d'une banque au rez de chaussée d'un
autre peine aux étages supérieurs selon
plusieurs personnes avec lesquelles nous
avons pu parler et bien aucune victime
ne serait à déplorer mais d'autres
bombardements ont été largement entendu
en périphérie de la ville je vous le
rappelle cette ville de nicolet et les
derniers verrous que tentent de prendre
la mérule maintenant depuis plusieurs
semaines avant de tenter une offensive
sur odessa